what's happening there reject nation we
are here today at the spider-man no way
home premiere i know we told you guys
we're going to be here we didn't tell
you why or how we got in all cousins
that is not hyperbolic that is a hundred
percent fact so whichever big ones come
by
coy gets major first divs on all of them
and frankly he cares more to do that
than we do everyone you want to talk to
coy is gonna talk so don't hate me in
the comments please yeah no this is more
me just being worried about you and
corey would do a much better job than
what we would do by the way i love these
i do you're professional dude yeah we're
just like hey whatever gets us to watch
the movie at the premiere over here i
want to thank sony want to thank marvel
i want to thank the real rejects because
without them i wouldn't be able to have
this beautiful beautiful people that is
you watching this so this isn't a
magical team up observe the the magic
team up of the microphone
symbolic of this amazing union that we
have here today i can't wait to watch
the movie koi i can't wait for you to
talk to a bunch of people i'll talk to
certain people john will talk to you i'm
gonna frantically come up with questions
as everyone approaches and hope i don't
embarrass everyone
this can be fun on the fly
[Music]
we're trying to talk to jacob battle on
it's filipino so i'm going to use that
to wiggle my way into a good
conversation
because i'm half filipino
using my race to edge my way
while all us poor white folks
you are here at the movie of the year
it's a hype time i've seen you since
london how's the world been man well i
mean other than the world
it's been amazing you know i can't say
enough i mean london's been great we
just came from new york a few days ago
and it's been very stressful very tiring
but it's been amazing i think we've had
a great time i really miss everyone so
it's been awesome so i i don't like
spoilers so don't infer this as a
spoiler question avoid any spoilers but
if you could be any villain in the mcu
because i know when the comics ned turns
into hobgoblin but anyone that you
identify with and go like man i'd love
to play that guy
i mean the hobgoblin no no no i was
kidding
oh gosh i mean anyone i feel like it's
really tough to uh choose they're all
really amazing i think i really like
willem defoe because he's like the best
that's like a joke with him and uh yeah
because he's like he's just a really lit
goblin
so what is the guy in the chairs
playlist from day to day because if
you're stuck in that chair you're
navigating you're helping spidey out
what's your go-to like main jump track i
feel like he's definitely really rocking
with j cole who's really well with
kendrick all that good stuff yeah all
right so he's a modernist yeah
absolutely i respect that you got a
question yeah i wanted to ask god damn
it that transition felt so unnatural to
me like coy walking a child into a red
carpet interview amateur i'm filipino
myself i know you're filipino pinoy
pride baby
and uh i was actually following this
story about how like that in the
philippines there was this big petition
going around for don't don't delay no
way home ph
yeah and so i was wondering if the guy
in the chair what would you advice for
the friends in the philippines of how
you can avoid some spoilers in the
meantime or the next few weeks
i mean probably turn off social media
i'm so sorry that you guys can't watch
it immediately i wish i could do
something about it but try your hardest
to maybe not see anything
and you will enjoy it just as much as
everyone else and you will probably have
a greater sense of satisfaction because
it'll be a bit longer but you guys
deserve better for sure that's an
amazing answer i appreciate that and
then a little pivot here i just wanted
to ask you like easily the funniest guy
in the spider-man franchise right now
but i'm curious
who would you say is probably the
funniest person on set when the camera's
not rolling i mean jimmy fox is
hilarious
uh zendaya is low-key pretty funny
um
and i mean high key i'm the funniest guy
ever so i can't really lie yeah so yeah
so yeah
i was a pleasure to meet you thank you
so much for your time man boys going to
try to get jk simmons
i can't think of anything you need to
ask her yeah go ahead and get him but he
did briefly talk to simon liu
so truly thank you for like investing
that much dude thank you oh yeah well
what koi was interviewing them
tom holland walked right past us
[Applause]
i am obsessed with the green goblin
through and through i learned to read
with spider-man that's how i learned
english and gringott was my favorite
character where are you from i'm from
here but i was two so i literally i had
the photos parallel to the words making
me feel like an old man
but the green goblin was so vibrant and
so accessible and so interesting from
the beginning so like how green was my
goblin was how i learned so much english
beautiful i was wondering when you came
back to the role how it felt to slightly
adjust and modernize such a character
that's been iconic for so many years you
know i didn't think about you know just
continue from where we left off and of
course the story really tells you where
to go with it but as far as
going back into it you know it's it's
strong you put that suit on it's uh
you're back in the group pretty quickly
the glider's like riding a bike
yeah everything's a little different
same but different yeah but riding a
bike yeah so we're in the world of meme
culture and one of the first giant memes
was i'm something of a scientist myself
what's been your favorite variation of
that meme that you've seen oh god i
tried not to
follow these things you know it warps my
mind that's fair that's a dark place the
internet
so in fighting both tom and toby over
the years how is it different in the in
the prep mentally now that things are a
little bit more cgi versus practical was
there any different process that's not
true
that things are more cgi now that's not
really true in the fighting for example
in the original yes some things were a
little cruder there was more wire work
and maybe some the cgi wasn't as
sophisticated but we did a lot of
just flat out fighting you know
stage
fighting
and we did as well in this uh some of
the flying some of that stuff changes
but
as far as the actual
fighting yeah it was pretty dumb and
dirty oh that makes me happy last
question for you it's fun
that roots it also because that kind of
that kind of pays for
you know that puts you there then then
when you've got the scenes where you got
to be for you're threatening him it has
some teeth
because you got you got something going
yeah yeah now my last question is the
goblin serum causes a voice in the head
is that something that you experienced
as a separate entity and reading the
script either time
ah
i can't remember to tell you the truth
the government voice is talking to me
now there's plenty anyway thank you so
much man i appreciate it
willem dafoe is the green goblin
so i just want to throw out there that i
did get to meet willem dafoe myself that
night too it was actually after the
movie so it wasn't on camera i went up
to him and i said that green goblin is
one of my all-time favorite villains
from comic book movies i was so
surprised by just how much you managed
to out do
what you did all the way back in 2002
and now with what he didn't know at home
it was like incredible just how much
better he is asked to take a photo josh
saw me taking a photo and then he uh
inserted himself in there
i do all the lifting after koi does all
the heavy lifting oh yeah we met kevin
feige too don't cast that spell
i am i'm a little nervous this is
actually my first premiere red carpet
interview yeah don't don't be nervous
you're doing great i'm so much more
relaxed just now to me so you open down
this is good i feel like we're bonding
with each passing appearance i feel like
you know wong's profile has risen to the
point that like when the shang qi
trailer dropped i feel like the one
thing people freaked out about more than
anything was you versus abomination like
were you aware of that just fan response
and what does that feel like no it
wasn't you know they just you know have
portal will travel you know they tell me
where to go i'm a
massive marvel fan so you know
the possibilities for me seem to be kind
of a bit endless got an email off kevin
feige once that said this is fast
becoming the wcu
how about that well to that effect i
mean if they were to give you like a
disney plush show or something like that
who would you want to have as like your
partner your buddy aside from you know
strange any of those you know familiar
faces
yeah you know they'll pop in it uh but
uh i don't know
i don't know it could be a film could be
yeah it could be a series it'd be great
i do have a few ideas yeah yeah keep
them tight to the best yeah if it
happens it happens then i'll
unfurl everything yeah it's good i like
a surprise and i mean you know dr
strange obviously is is the sorcerer
supreme but i feel like wong is the guy
who really keeps things in order at the
sanctum you know you're kind of like the
nick fury of the mystical side of the
marvel universe how how do you feel like
would you accept that role yeah i'll say
that i'll say that you know um
yes i will absolutely okay i got one
more before i pass it off to him really
quick who has possesses more innate
mystical abilities
wong or wallace the necromancer from
what we do in the shadows
i improvise the uh spitting on a dead
corpse uh
which can no longer be done now these
days so that's probably the that's the
extra juju yeah yeah good sport hayley
joel yeah absolutely need to spit on him
yeah i'm gonna pass this off real quick
to my man here thanks for talking though
appreciate you hey man
we had you like he do great he did
incredible incredible work yeah
absolutely this guy can you hear him
that's for you that's where you hear
that outside that's the magic ability
for you it's true we had you on collider
heroes a while back and we talked about
sandwiches a ton we did we had a whole
like theme of what sandwiches different
people would enjoy yeah we did didn't we
so we were talking deadly class when you
came on heroes and that is one of my
favorite books of all time hard stuff
how do you think wong would fare in that
universe
oh it'd be over it'd be open in an
episode
that's it we need to make it happen i
appreciate it man thank you so much good
to see you again
enjoy the sandwiches try to talk to the
writers
i don't know what they did on the movie
i've been covering spider-man no way
home all year long on our youtube
channel and you are my first red carpet
interview ever that's not a lie they
were actually the first interview that i
did but you know through the jacob
battle on one and their first because i
figured you guys would probably care
more about that it's a jesus christ baby
can you please turn that down
cleaning your goddamn house
[Music]
thanks turn it down so i feel very
honored right now i'm sorry
it's like the first batch of pancakes
you could just throw this out we're
seeing all these returning villains
coming back which villain would you say
you were most particular about writing
for or was your favorite to write for i
would say the one that we're allowed to
talk about
[Laughter]
we saw a few of them in the trailer so
i'd imagine there's been a few that you
would like to mention it was such an
honor a daunting experience uh getting
to write for uh alfred and albert molina
and uh will defoe i'm afraid i know i'm
allowed to say these names but those two
i know we're allowed to say so we'll
just stop there's three you're allowed
to say there's anyone else we enjoyed
writing for you two but well let me help
out here in the trailer you saw lizard
sandman doc ock electro green goblin
a thing that happens with like
spider-man 3 and amazing spider-man 2
was peop they were kind of criticized
for being a little over convoluted with
villains so how did you guys go about
approaching balancing all this villains
what was what was the approach you guys
had to make sure it all flowed so well
ultimately it had to be um true to peter
parker the peter parker the tom hollands
peter parker it had to be his story it
couldn't feel like it was a tail wagging
the dog it had to feel like they were
coming here in a way that
was transformative for not only peter
parker but also the characters that were
coming into this world it couldn't just
be a concept sort of dancing across the
stage hopefully that
they would impact each other and affect
each other that was part of the
challenge so it didn't feel like it was
just a gimmick we were trying to pull
off we always try to ride up to the
villains that's what we tried in the
first in the first movie and in far from
home and
in this one we just did the same thing
we tried to write up to the villains but
you want the villains
to be their stories to be in service of
the hero you know it's all about the
hero's journey through the movie and so
like chris said you can't let the tail
wag the dog and so we just applied the
same logic but we just had more villains
to deal with this time but we just had
to stay true to that this seems like
it'd be very very hard to top this movie
and we haven't even seen the movie yet
and i'm already like how could you
possibly top this spider-man movie do
you think this is going to be the
biggest spider-man movie yet it was a
lot i mean there was like thing there
was it there was like i would say the
first draft felt like kitchen sink and
it was like you know what we love all
this stuff but there's certain things
that we we had to sharpen it and hone to
take it away because there were so many
things that everyone wanted to try to
put into this but ultimately though you
have to whatever if it doesn't serve the
story if it doesn't serve the characters
then
save it for another movie so yeah
there's some things we got to pull out
of the sink
um
that um
maybe they'll use the next time
i love to hear those suckers
the next guys i hope it is the biggest
and uh and i hope i hope we get to do
some more and try to do something even
bigger
well thank you guys so much for your
time i cannot wait to watch this movie
thank you guys throw that right out
right yeah let's see that's
coming up you're my first interview
how's it going guys
i haven't seen you since the very
beginning of spider-verse and it's so
good to see you guys again
and i think i saw you at freaks that
first screening in san diego so it's
been a little less of a minute
started at the middle and now now we're
here but that new trailer you guys like
as as the guy that was i think the first
audience that saw a kingpin in all of
his glory yeah
i can't believe it exceeded my
expectations what's the feedback bit
dude life changing hearing miguel like
seeing that whole experience like what's
it been like to receive that from the
audience oh man oh gosh we wanted to
freak people out a little bit yeah and
and uh it looks like we succeeded yeah
yeah i hope
the response has been really
overwhelming it's been really exciting
to feel like we're on the right track so
the look feels like elka max felt so
when you read the alcamax and the
scratchiness it all feels so authentic
what was the idea to have it open with
the aged up miles was that always the
idea from the beginning
um yeah i mean the story takes place uh
like a year later
and the idea was at the end of that
first movie you didn't realize it but it
was a year later we spent a lot of time
thinking about how it was going to play
in a movie theater and in a room and at
your house going what is the first thing
you want to see
after three years and it was like you
want to see miles again and how and i
don't want to know because i hate
spoilers how long until we find out
collectively what the villainy looks
like is that a trailer two trailer three
i i i
you know you think there was a plan
but we were just like let's get to the
end of this teaser we'll figure the rest
out i imagine the next thing you see you
probably it may be
who knows or not they'll say that uh
they
the nice are nice uh friends at sony
publicity have other
a little another movie they have to open
first we might be present
now is there any swearing from the year
2099 we're going to hear from oscar
isaac
i will say that i did
possibly write some futuristic
swear words
it's my main question but one last one
for you guys did you have a conversation
with haley once she made her live action
debut in marvel comparing how she was
going to play her spider gwen was there
a dichotomy and duality conversation
no she's such a good actor she she
uh can play a million different parts
and they're all
a little bit different and she's too
much of a pro to pit us against one
another that's right the other thing is
fun fact she recorded
most of her lines for the teaser
from a closet
at a junket for another project probably
hawkeye it's true okay i lied one last
question we got sankevich's kingpin we
got bagley's ultimate goblin we've got a
beautiful medley of a multiverse
is there any artist or anyone you can
tease for us die hard comic fans oh i
can't tease it but i promise you'll be
satisfied okay that's enough of tease
for me i hate spoilers i just want to
know as much as i can thank you guys so
very much you truly are the spider-man
guys to my heart you guys made it such a
comic fan movie i really appreciate it
every morsel i can't wait i appreciate
it thank you guys yes cheers you guys
thank you
[Music]